you know things you're talking about are
all kind of playing out technology is
the son of the [ __ ] technology doesn't
care that you've been unbelievable at
your craft for 30 years right technology
even cared that my dad's contemporaries
that came over from Russia in 1978 moved
to LA made 2 bucks an hour being a cab
driver work 20 hours a day saved every
dollar for 13 years had you know paid
their dues could didn't see their family
saved all their money bought a couple of
black cars actually built a business
saved all their money worked every day
for 30 years finally getting to the
moment where eating all that [ __ ] might
pay off just a little bit and then uber
came along and put them out of business
totally like technology didn't care that
you or grandfather came from Europe
worked 80 hours a day for his whole life
built a small little bookstore your dad
came along your mom came along made it
bigger now it was your turn and it's a
real great base and you're gonna take it
and Amazon came along and put you out of
business technologists thing here like
like I don't know what to tell you like
this is called capitalism this is the
way it works and nobody's going to cry
for you and nobody's going to cry for
anybody that's the point and so of
course that's happening this always
happens